Paul Rudd has become one of Hollywood's
most beloved actors over his more than
25-year career he started everything
from clueless to hit comedies like
anchorman and this is 40 now Rudd stars
opposite himself in a new Netflix series
called living with yourself he portrays
Miles a man who is unhappy with his life
and visits a spa hoping to turn things
around in this clip Myles returns home
to find he has been replaced by a better
version of himself with my wife shortly
and now I'm being attacked by someone
who looks like me in a diaper
[Laughter]
Paul good morning welcome morning
Entertainment Weekly says Paul Ridd Paul
Rudd gives two of his best performances
in this show they're both really good
what's it like playing opposite yourself
it's just a nightmare it was a dance it
was in a way in a way it is yeah it was
a challenge and I was excited to try it
yeah and I and you know normally when
you're acting opposite somebody you
don't know where it seems going to go
because you're what you do is dependent
on what the other person is doing and so
this was the first time I ever got to
kind of think of a scene and really
construct it from the ground how
literally well practically how did you
do it it's like a green screen or you
got a dummy there you know a lot of
times I mean it's not it's not an
unfamiliar convention but there are many
ways you can do it and I found that for
me the way that it was that's the way it
worked best was to record the audio for
both characters whatever character was
driving the scene was the one that I
would film first but I would act
I wouldn't act with an a double or an
acting partner I would put a little
earwig in my ear I would listen to the
opposite line so if I'm playing the new
version of the character I can hear the
old version
because there's somebody off screen
hitting the cue and then I would study
that take once we settled on the proper
master take that we would use I'd switch
over to the other guy and I would see
where I was moving and what gestures I
was doing on what words and then I would
hear it when I did the reverse and
that's where the it felt like
choreography because I thought oh yeah
on that line I walked that way so I will
turn my head and walk then and and it
became a little easier as it went along
but it was a I would think it could get
pretty confusing yeah at times but like
anything I guess you just get into the
zone yeah and and we were able to do it
on a fairly you know in a short amount
of time I would think it would be acting
goal though to have this this type of
role that you get to play two different
personalities but while looking exactly
the same you know you've got something
Paul when you get to deliver a line that
says is there a reason why I'm wearing a
diaper
laughs out loud funny when it appeared
on the scene and you shot that in a park
did other people see you outside because
it is a very very funny scene yeah
actually the very the very first week we
film funny which we moved up in the
schedule because the weather was going
to change and there a cold front
happening there was a lot of running
outside of the first scene yeah the
opening of the show I'm running through
the woods in a diaper I could actually
emerge from a grave wearing a diaper and
we shot it in a park and and you were
actually the great yeah and they're
people riding their bikes somewhere I
mean that's another roll people we've
seen you in your father
this being ant-man mean that you were
now cooler to your children's friends I
don't know I mean I think if I'm cooler
to know Tom Holland that's about it I I
think that there it's it is exciting for
my kids and for their friends look of
recognition though when people come over
the house like you know little people
with children and they like wait a
minute that your dad is he's a well you
know I mean I think I've been friends
with my my kids are 14 and 9 I think
that you know they're friends I've known
now for a while but kids are maybe
interested for about two seconds and
then they want to just kind of play with
it
so yeah it was playing a superhero
something that you ever thought you
would do no I mean it just you know that
was I never thought too much about it I
wanted to play lots of different parts
and different genres and all kinds of
characters but that wasn't anything that
I really anticipated and so when it
happened it was a pleasant surprise it's
just another part or is it maybe it
comes with a lot of global recognition
absolutely it's you know it's certainly
the most visible thing that I've ever
done and it was also the first thing
that I ever did that was really suitable
for younger audiences can I just go back
to living with yourself because all this
happens at the top happy spot so just
think about that for a second run by two
Korean gentlemen and when you first get
there who's walking out the door that
was a surprise right yeah there's the
you know the whole premise of the show
is I play a guy named Miles who's just
not in the best name was George till you
change it tomorrow
who's George right but I have played
Georgia I mean I played five different
Georgia big miles well yeah I was I was
thinking of my fantasy football team and
I was like I had Jacksonville defense
and I thought miles Jack because his
name is miles Elliott and Tim Greenberg
the writer when we when we Nix George we
were trying to come up with other names
and he sort of Elliot and I think he
came up with Elliott because he had his
EQ um the depths of the Paul Rudd
psychology did playing your best and
worst self put you in touch with your
best and worst self it makes me really
how I you know my approach to life and
all of that in the way that I would I
guess if I'm playing any character and I
have dealing with these kinds of themes
but no it is the demons come out demons
he was coming out the door the superstar
coming out the door didn't you say no I
did I know it's a great show and we
appreciate you
living with yourself premieres this
Friday on Netflix